uy
si estáis aquí es que también habéis
sobrevivido a la resaca emocional del
cambio de año
resaca emocional quizás no suene el
nombre esa patología pero los síntomas
se agudizan durante las fiestas
navideñas y estoy segura que más de un
aquí los habrá sufrido por ejemplo esa
sensación de que se te hinchan las
narices que se te atraganta la bromita
inoportuna que se desencaja la ceja por
esos comentarios que van con segunda
vamos lo que se conoce como la
sobredosis por exposición al tío
graciosete
oa sus variedades más comunes como la
abuela chapada a la antigua o el jefe de
los chistes machistas o el colega del
gimnasio con aspiraciones a cuñado
todos tienen en común que te dan ganas
de hacer las maletas e irte a pasar'
diciembre a una isla desierta donde no
te cuenten cuentos
si os sirve de consuelo esta reacción
casi alérgica a las discusiones
incómodas las hemos tenido todos en
algún momento y por lo visto tiene
explicación el centro de investigaciones
pew que está basado en washington hace
encuestas a nivel global acerca de
tendencias políticas y sociales y nos
muestran que en los últimos años ha
crecido el distanciamiento entre los de
derechas y las izquierdas
los separatistas y los nacionalistas los
creyentes y los ateos los del madrid y
los del barça incluso los carnívoros y
los vegetarianos por qué pues porque
cada vez vivimos más y mejor aislados en
burbujas ideológicas donde cada uno
consume noticias diferentes se muda a
urbanizaciones homogéneas solo tiene
amigos con los que tiene ideas parecidas
y claro bloquea a cualquiera que se
atreva a postear algo que te caiga
pesado es lo que en inglés se conoce
como el efecto eco chamber en español la
cámara de eco
y como vivimos evitando el contacto con
los del otro extremo no vaya a ser que
nos contagien algo las ideas que tenemos
acerca de sus opiniones son las
historias absurdas y exageradas que nos
llegan a través de unos medios de
información que viven del clic y del
like
y en estas estamos en un estado de
paranoia en el que todos creen que
nosotros somos los cuerdos y los otros
son los locos donde vemos cada vez más
muros en las fronteras políticas contra
la diversidad recortes en ayudas
sociales y vigilancia policial por todas
partes
hay expertos que dicen que este fenómeno
es muy normal que el ser humano es un
animal tribal es decir que tiende hacia
lo familiar y le da miedo el cambio la
diferencia es que hemos entrado en una
etapa de la historia global donde los
cambios son muchos y muy rápidos y nos
tienen a todos como alucinando además
que estas alucinaciones colectivas por
miedo a un futuro incierto están guiando
y desviando la política más que nunca
las redes sociales permiten que la ira
la desconfianza y el resentimiento se
multipliquen y se propaguen como una
plaga
y el verdadero peligro surge cuando
sentimientos de miedo se convierten en
actos de odio
en critical engagement que es la
organización educativa para el
compromiso crítico que yo dirijo
exploramos con adolescentes de todo el
mundo cuáles sería la fórmula para hacer
frente a esta epidemia del rechazo a lo
diferente porque la estamos viendo tanto
en el parlamento británico como en
familias en cataluña en las calles de
chicago en los estadios de fútbol en
serbia y en los barrios en venezuela
después de muchas lluvias de ideas y
herramientas creativas para la
transformación del conflicto hemos dado
con la receta para tener más y mejores
encuentros que no encontronazos con los
que piensan de manera diferente a
nosotros estáis preparados para
escucharla
la receta incluye
instrucciones para una consulta previa
un examen minucioso del paciente un
diagnóstico objetivo y un tratamiento
personalizado pasamos al paso número 1
la consulta antes de ir recetándole nada
a nadie
hay que pasar consulta y preferiblemente
en persona por muy pesado que te caiga
el paciente
igual que la enfermera de urgencias al
verte no sale corriendo gritando dios
mío es un enfermo que no me contagia
pues no es muy recomendable que te pases
todas las cenas familiares evitando a tu
tío y bloqueando lo del whatsapp por sus
comentarios acerca de los vecinos
dominicanos del tercero
si te vas a dedicar a erradicar la
intolerancia en el mundo o en tu casa no
te va a quedar otra que ir a trabajar a
zonas de conflicto en esas situaciones
en las que sientes que los síntomas de
la ceja desencajada y la acidez de
estómago se agudizan ahí es donde hace
falta la intervención porque de nada nos
sirve ir pasando consulta en nuestros
círculos sobre protectores donde todo el
mundo te hace esto a todo lo que dices y
te da un montón de pulgares hacia arriba
y cáritas felices a lo que compartes en
los medios porque ahí no vamos a
aprender qué es lo que le pasa a la otra
gente y no haber esperanza de que tu tío
se cure de ese miedo irracional al que
no es como él
pasamos entonces al segundo paso de esta
receta que es el examen el examen físico
psicológico y emocional de otra persona
y esto lleva tiempo así que hay que
armarse de valor y de curiosidad
ortega y gasset que no era médico pero
como filósofo se ocupaba de las
dolencias existenciales decía que uno es
uno y sus circunstancias y nuestra labor
es dar con esas circunstancias porque tu
tío o tu compañera de clase o tu
peluquero o tu ex tienen esas opiniones
que a ti te resultan tan indignantes
para dar con estas circunstancias hay
algunos trucos por ejemplo escuchar
atentamente esto suena seguramente lo
habéis escuchado un millón de veces pero
es importante escuchar sin poner cara de
pero que me estás contando que es alguna
de las que tenemos por aquí esta gente
de adelante también es importante hacer
preguntas objetivas que no suenen a
reproche es mucho más fácil que alguien
se abra a contarte sus opiniones y le
preguntas cosas del estilo y por qué
piensas eso o qué experiencias has
tenido para llegar a esa conclusión o
conoces a alguien que encaja en ese
perfil
como mínimo aprenderemos algo nuevo
acerca una perspectiva que es diferente
a la nuestra y si tenemos suerte con
tanta pregunta nuestro tío acabe
cuestionándose sus propias opiniones y
ahí cuando esté receptivo podemos pasar
al tercer paso el diagnóstico
todos sabemos que no hay nada más
incómodo que alguien te diagnostiquen de
mente cerrada o de ignorante o de facha
o de progre o de lo que sea
pero amar y a nosotros no somos
doctorados en el arte de la comunicación
sutil ni siquiera los que estamos en
esta alfombra roja especialmente cuando
nos encontramos con alguien con quien
estamos en desacuerdo y cuanto más
cercana a la persona peor nos damos
cuenta de lo difícil que explica es
explicarle a alguien nuestras opiniones
con claridad y con tranquilidad
un especialista en comunicación igual
que un buen médico de cabecera tiene
esta habilidad de expresarle sus
opiniones al manojo de nervios que tiene
delante
con tacto y con todos los detalles que
sean necesarios para conseguir que el
otro no se niegue a escuchar y que acabe
considerando algunas recomendaciones
por experiencia personal la mejor forma
de conseguir que alguien escuche lo que
él tienes que decir es empezar por
reconocer que tú tampoco tienes todas
las respuestas que no está 100% seguro
de cuál es la vacuna en contra del
racismo que también te generan dudas las
diferentes ramas del feminismo que no
conoces la cura contra la guerra en
siria y que no eres inmune a ese chiste
que aunque es políticamente incorrecto
te hace gracia mostrarse vulnerable es
la forma más certera y si la que más
cuesta de conseguir que nuestras
conversaciones difíciles no acaben en
retirada con portazo incluido
y así podemos pasar ya a la parte más
delicada de esta receta el tratamiento
reconozco muy poca gente que la haga
ilusión ir a que le pinchen vacunas con
las agujas así de grandes o que se tome
un comprimido en sobre por gusto
igualmente no podemos esperar que
alguien le sienta bien que le des
curarle a base de sermones
cuando el recomendamos nuestra solución
milagrosa a alguien tenemos que tener en
cuenta que lo que te sirve a ti le
puedes generar un sarpullido a otra
persona
es mucho más efectivo intentar dar con
el tratamiento personalizado que
realmente encaje con lo que necesita el
otro y el tratamiento puede ir desde
pequeñas dosis de pensamiento crítico
una vez al mes a una intervención más
directa la próxima vez que tu jefe haga
un chiste verde o incluso sea una
terapia de pareja con el colega acuñado
a ver si encontráis algo en común ir
construyendo desde ahí
tengo que advertir a algunos efectos
secundarios que podéis notar durante la
administración de estos tratamientos
experimentales no tanto en la otra
persona sino vosotros mismos por ejemplo
podéis acabar dando cuenta de que no
lleva instante razón o que no habéis
entendido bien lo que os quería explicar
nuestro tío o incluso en un caso de cada
1000 puede que cambie de opinión y
tranquila que eso no significa que
tengas las defensas bajas o que sufras
de un carácter débil o que te hayan
reclutado los del otro bando solo
significa que te has abierto a una
segunda opinión y esto puede ser súper
útil el resto de tu vida para entender
los conflictos desde diferentes
perspectivas
bueno ahora que hemos pasado por paso
número 1 la consulta paso número 2
el examen después el diagnóstico y el
tratamiento hace falta mencionar los
efectos adversos de esta receta que
todavía está en fase experimental
primero nunca va a ser fácil operar en
zonas de conflicto algunos suplementos
de paciencia un buen concentrado de
empatía y unos tapones para ignorar esas
frases que te hierve en la sangre van a
ser indispensables y además si quieres
puedes probar la meditación y quizás te
ayuda a aceptar que siempre haber casos
crónicos de tíos graciosete es que ni
quieren sus consultas ni quieren sus
tratamientos
el segundo efecto adverso es que lo más
importante para no acabar
convirtiéndonos en unos cazadores
despiadados de tíos graciosete es
detectar en nosotros mismos
los síntomas prematuros del síndrome del
salvador
a veces parece que el pensamiento
crítico apunta a un estado elevado que
es imposible de explicar sólo en
palabras a los mortales donde todo cobra
sentido y donde los problemas tienen
soluciones sencillas y lógicas a ver los
pies en la tierra que el hecho de que
nosotros intentemos ser más conscientes
de lo que pensamos de cómo actuamos y
del mundo nos alrededor no nos convierte
en iluminados que podamos ir practicando
de primeros auxilios a los demás aunque
nos cuesta admitirlo la gente tiene
derecho a no estar de acuerdo contigo
y eso no los hace menos humanos y
mientras vivían sin hacerle daño a nadie
tampoco es una excusa para odiar los
y el tercer efecto adverso
y el último
es la frustración y la decepción que
vamos a sentir cuando no veamos los
progresos que nosotros esperábamos en
las personas con las que entremos en
contacto en estos momentos es muy bueno
recordar que practicar el pensamiento
crítico te ofrece la posibilidad de
encontrar en el desacuerdo una
oportunidad para enseñar pero también
para aprender
quizás incluso podemos llegar a aprender
algo del tío graciosete porque si lo
pensamos bien el mundo es tan complicado
y nuestras mentes están falibles que es
poco probable que todo lo que creamos y
defendamos ahora mismo sea correcto así
que nos recomiendo a todos pasar por un
chequeo ideológico como mínimo una vez
cada año nuevo
en definitiva para recetarle pensamiento
crítico a otras personas tenemos que
empezar por ser críticos con nosotros
mismos y con nuestras ideas favoritas
incluyendo todas las ideas que yo os
acabo de presentar desde este escenario
de hecho os propongo un reto vamos a
empezar aquí y ahora mismo porque qué
mejor laboratorio para experimentar con
conversaciones difíciles que un teatro
lleno de mentes inconformes así que
presente la persona que tienes al lado
pregúntale y tú qué piensas acerca de
todo esto
porque quizás
la clave mágica para tener más
transfusiones de experiencias y de
perspectivas entre personas que se creen
incompatibles es perderle el miedo al
contagio gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]